thanks Jared and I'm excited to be here
I'm one of those people who have been
here for the last 4 years
so this conference is always one of the
highlights of the spring for me and the
talk I'm gonna give today is actually
really specially tied into this New York
City our conference because I'm gonna be
talking about my experience working in
healthcare technology and accelerating
cancer research using our and in
particular I'm going to talk about some
of the challenges that that we faced at
the company I worked for Flatiron Health
over the last few years both as a
smaller start-up which was a talk I gave
in this very stage two years ago I
talked about the first year and some of
the challenges we encountered using our
and so today I'm gonna refresh some of
that material that I presented two years
ago and then tell you what has happened
in the last two years and what the next
set of challenges we face are and so a
little bit about me in my background so
I come from a world of academic
biostatistics and first in graduate
school and then as a faculty member at
Cleveland Clinic and so some of the the
work that I did there was really focused
on using our I was working pretty
independently so I could use whatever
language I wanted for the most part a
few times in grad school I used SAS
under duress but I mostly I used our and
I was coding by myself you know for
better or for worse a lot of academics
are working pretty independently so no
one was really reviewing my code I
didn't have to follow any standards I
just wanted to get the research right
and so after doing that for a few years
as Jared mentioned I he convinced me to
move to New York from Cleveland and I
joined a healthcare tech company called
Flatiron healthcare because I was
interested in a faster pace and a
potential for more immediate impact to
my work and so once I got to Flatiron
things changed in terms of the technical
environment I was in it wasn't just I
used whatever I wanted to get the job
done now I'm in this environment that is
a tech companies so there are many
software engineers using Python all of
the data lived in relational data
so we used variants of sequel some of my
co-workers at the time you SAS - I
obviously wanted to use our but it
wasn't really as clear-cut of a decision
as it was in the past so before I get
into how we made some of these decisions
over time just want to tell you a little
bit about what we do at the company to
give some some context so our mission is
to improve lives by learning from the
experience of every cancer patient so
might ask well every cancer patient
we're not doing that already and the
answer's no so right now about only 5%
or so of cancer patients are enrolled in
clinical trials the other about 95% are
going to their oncologist they're
getting some kinds of treatment and some
of them are getting better and some of
them are getting worse and unfortunately
a lot of that information isn't really
getting used for research so it's being
captured an electronic health record but
the format that it's being captured and
being siloed in different locations and
not being standardized it's just not
necessarily research grade data so right
now for the most part we're not learning
from the experience of that 95% of
cancer patients and so that's what I've
been working on the last few years as
well as my my co-workers trying to
process some of this oncology based EHR
data at scale and so how do we do that
we don't look at the structured data so
those are discrete fields that actually
have standardized data inputs things
like demographics and diagnosis and in
labs but yet they still need to be
standardized and harmonized they're
missing and complex on their own in
their raw form we also take unstructured
data so those are things that live in
things like physician notes radiology
reports free text it could be in a you
know a scanned document that's scanned
at 45 degrees and handwritten and has
things crossed out and often there's
very clinically complex information in
there so what we actually do is we use a
combination of technology and clinically
trained human abstractors to do that and
so we use technology in the form of both
software we develop and then models and
algorithms that we use to surface
exactly the
right information to the right people to
then extract that information in the
clinical context and so once we process
all of this data and standardize it we
then have a combined analytic data set
of research grade data that we can then
use to answer some of these questions
and so flashback to years to me on the
stage giving this talk about my
experience from 2015 when I joined when
it was still a smaller startup that year
we had about 100 to 150 people most of
them or at least of a vast majority were
software engineers the quantitative
sciences team that I was on had one
person when I started and then when I
came and give this talk so it's on
YouTube I called it a statistician walks
into a tech company because I started
this job and I was like where where did
I end up Who am I how did I get here how
do I work in this environment and so
that was the the talk I gave two years
ago about that experience and so over
that year we scaled from about a hundred
to about 250 or more and so over doubled
in size in that one year and the
quantitative Sciences team did grow from
one to ten over the course of that year
but as I mentioned the choice of what
language to use was not clear-cut so the
team coming in at the time actually was
predominantly SAS users in that first
year and so you know I was coming from
an are background and that's really what
I wanted to use but it's just not a
clear-cut answer of what the best choice
is here and so people did have some
experience with our but this is their
self rate of per Finch than me at time a
higher for that first year's team and so
some of them had no experience but a lot
were beginners so maybe they had seen it
used it a little bit you know perhaps
alike a lot of people in this room today
who were just getting into our and so
early on some of the the challenges that
we faced in that first year were the
basic things of actually just which
language do we use and this is an actual
list of pros and cons that my colleague
Melissa came up with one late night we
were trying to decide and she wrote down
all the reasons to use sauce
and all the reasons to use are and some
of them were very practical and some of
them were more fun so for sass it made
sense because we collaborated with
pharma companies as a healthcare tech
company and although many of them do use
our there is still Easter conception
that a lot of them use SAS we had also
paid money for a license and so we
didn't want to waste all that money and
for her and others in the team it was
intuitive they had experience with it it
felt familiar then on the our side there
were things like the community around
our we thought it aligned with our
values as a company I thought it was the
future we also thought it worked really
well with our tools that we used like
Max and get for version control and then
my favorite reason she had was that the
sweatshirts and the swag we're much
better for our and so she really liked
the sweatshirt and then that night we
made the decision because in a small
company you can just make a decision
like this two people one night and then
we were gonna use are so great decided
then we had to figure out how to
cultivate our culture and we started
things like starting an internal art
package it was really not much to speak
of at all in the beginning
but at least it was the beginning we
also started a user group where we would
share information and knowledge you know
we're gonna tuck that when you'll know
you need a slack channel to do anything
so we started a slack channel for our we
started having trainings and doing
targeted hiring if anybody is in this
stage I would really recommend there's a
blog post from the Airbnb data science
team about using our packages and
education to scale data science and a
lot of these things that we used in that
first year are really covered very well
in that blog post so did these things in
that first year work well if you go from
the time of hire to 2016 when I gave
that last talk here there was a big
change in terms of self rate of
proficiency so people on the team were
starting to call themselves intermediate
and advanced users everybody had started
using our which was a really a big
success and then so enter the next phase
and this is this is what's really
happened in the last two years since I
was here
so now we have a very different team and
a very different size so now the company
has moved from 250 then 2 over 500 now
and the composition of the team now
actually their primary language at time
of hire was very different so now most
people coming into the team we're using
are before they joined and they were not
beginners or with no experience there
were a lot of advanced and expert users
in fact actually one of the original
data points when I did the survey a few
months ago it said well I thought I was
an expert before I joined and then I
recalibrated and realized I wasn't as
good as I thought
so I actually imputed that as advanced
but don't ever tell anyone I did
multiple single imputation here please
and so in that phase over the last two
years you know we've done a lot of the
same things that that we had done
earlier but going to the next stage so
we've instead of just starting this
internal art package we've grown it and
added a lot of functionality and really
tried to cultivate a user group and of
course once locked channels enough not
enough so we need multiple slot channels
and we've started to think about
standardization and having standards for
some of the things that we do quite
often as well as thinking about quality
control and unit tests and with an
emphasis on reproducibility so the work
that we've done has changed a lot since
the beginning so early on we were doing
like a small startup we didn't imagine a
lot of rapid prototyping a lot of quick
analyses in these last two years
actually a lot of our work has gone
towards things like publications or
collaborations with organizations like
the FDA and so when we think about those
things
a quick prototype probably isn't enough
we really need to change the way that
we're doing things and part of the way
that we do done that is having kind of
an agreed-upon shared set of packages
that help us move quickly and so you'll
recognize a lot of these here this is
just a small sample no coincidence there
a lot of them are from the tidy verse
and these help with both readability and
standardization
and our just much better tools to allow
us to move quickly I'll come back to
this in a little while though when we
talk about the trade-offs of actually
having a standard sort of packages and
why that's not always agreed upon the
other package that we've been using to
help us move quickly is our internal
package flatiron R and so that's the one
that we created internally for a lot of
functions for things like database
connections that that we use here and a
lot of functionality that we use often
and of course it has its own hex ticker
because you know if you really want
though something to be successful that's
the best way to get the message out
there and so some some more about that
internal package so it's things that
have functions that are specific to the
specific data format that we have
database connections standardizing those
across all of our databases so it's not
you know the most like exciting or sexy
type of functions there but they're
really useful functions that help us
move this faster so we also have things
like for example we work in oncology so
we do a lot of survival analyses and we
have some some kaplan-meier curve
functions that do them in a specific and
standardized way that match our
specifications and actually my colleague
Josh is in the audience and was really
helpful in getting some of those off the
ground so another thing if anybody has
worked in kind of the biomedical
research world you'll know the the joys
and frustrations of making a table one
it's just basically a table of baseline
characteristics of patients and so
there's nothing too fancy here it's
really looking at just a descriptive
statistics about the patient's but you
know you often have to do it in a very
specialized format and comparing the
groups and so it's just really nice to
have different kinds of helper functions
to do that and so there's this really
nice package called compare groups that
we use quite a bit and that allows us to
more easily do things that are specific
for this seems kind of a medical
research environment and so I mentioned
early on that we had some you know
starting to do some work in
collaborations
with companies work with organizations
like the FDA and so early on we had
thought actually one of the reasons to
use SAS was there is this misconception
out there that the FDA only looked at
SAS and that they were against our and
you know they had never actually said
that but that's what people really
thought and so one of the big pieces of
pushback we got early on was oh you
can't use our if you ever want to do
anything related to the FDA well fast
forward two years now and earlier this
year we had our first joint
collaborative publication with them come
out and all the analyses we did in our
and it turns out it's really not a big
deal at all and as long as we're using
the right reproducible standards it
hasn't been a problem and a little bit
more about this paper I think because
it's really interesting so this was
actually looking at characteristics of
real-world patients so those are those
ninety-five percent of patients that are
seeing their oncologist but not in a
clinical trial and this is in the
setting of advanced non-small-cell lung
cancer and so looking at those
real-world lung cancer patients compared
to patients in a clinical trial and one
of the things that we found in this
collaboration is that those are very
different types of patients so it's not
just that patients aren't being included
in this research but they're actually
very different in all of these different
ways in patient characteristics and so
what we think is that the studies that
are outcomes in these underrepresented
populations through world data are
actually essential for informing
real-world treatment decisions it came
in in January but happy to give you the
reference later so now in 2018 after
this two-year phase this was the
beginning of the year i resurveyed the
team and proficiency with r is now very
high almost everybody rates themselves
at advanced or higher or intermediate
and so i'm not going to necessarily
assume any causality here in terms of
what we did and what happened but i do
think that a lot of the things that
we've worked on over time have really
helped with this so are we done have we
you know succeeded is this no more
challenges
well have to tell you now although we
have come so far there are still
challenges that remain and next level
success looks different than what we've
done in the past so early on success was
things like deciding we were gonna use
our and getting sweatshirts now we have
what I think are kind of if I think of
them as grown-up problems to have so
these are the ones that are you know
harder to solve a little bit less fun
but our serious problem is when you get
to a more mature and more scale team and
so going forward for the next two years
a lot of the things that really are
really focusing on now is thinking about
balancing independence with
standardization so the independence
thing is is really twofold so from the
perspective of moving quickly we like to
have teams that can work independently
and it can do things that the way they
want to and just move fast also a lot of
people on the team coming from academic
backgrounds and I think that's really
ingrained in and if who we are and how
we think about ourselves is no one tells
me how to write my code no one tells me
which packages to use on the other hand
there are a lot of benefits of
standardization both in terms of the
packages that you use and the style that
you write in some of the best practices
and so I think trying to find that
balance of how much specification and
standardization do you need to have you
know we have a draft style guide but not
everybody follows it how much do we
enforce it those are some of the
questions that we're tackling right now
one of the biggest questions is how do
we find time to devote to infrastructure
and balance the opportunity costs
because we are growing so quickly every
hour that we spend on thinking about
planning and infrastructure there's an
hour that we take away from doing
something new and cool and exciting but
as you know it's not really sustainable
to only do those new cool exciting
things if you don't think about
investing and spending down on technical
debt and you know we actually a few
months ago when I did this survey I
asked what is the biggest barrier to you
for contributing
to our internal package or any of our
other infrastructure or coding culture
and the number one answer it wasn't lack
of desire it wasn't lack of skills or
restrictions and the functions it was
time people want to contribute we just
need to find how to balance the time and
how to protect that so another thing is
thinking about versioning and
maintenance of an internal our package
so once you have a package that's great
but then who is the owner of that
package how do you think about
maintaining it and especially when
you're thinking about working across
multiple teams where the ownership is is
less clear and not everybody has the
same amount of time to devote to it how
do you make that so that's fair and it
also is being maintained and then also I
mentioned earlier a lot of those
stickers that I had up were for tidy
verse packages so we loved them they're
great but should we require people to
use them this is the debate I see in
code reviews all the time going back and
forth someone says oh well you should
use you know some tidy verse package
here and someone's like well I'd really
like to do that in base R and so they go
back and forth and it's really hard to
know how much to just encourage verses
to enforce there and so this next phase
of growth so about two months ago
my colleague caught TNI we're thinking
about this with some other folks on the
team and we said you know we are really
at a decision point now we really need
to think about what this next phase of
growth is and change the strategy is for
how we figure this out and how we plan
about this going forward so we had a
meeting with the team and we presented
the problem and the motivation so the
the agenda was we talked about some of
these goals that we had then and the
goals that we have now and how they're
very different and need different
solutions and what some of the
challenges we face are and so we did
that to get people to acknowledge that
there were new challenges that we had to
address and to get buy-in and also to
get people excited about what could be
the next stages and how to actually be
part of that and so that you know two
years from now if I'm giving a talk
again that they could actually see some
of the work that they did
as part of the solution there so we
started a new working group CAUTI my
colleague did and then got started on on
planning and thinking about how where to
go from here and so the first things
that this group has done in the last few
months is starting off with the first
set of goals of defining things like
coding standards and best practices and
also it's not enough to define best
practices but think about how we should
hold ourselves accountable to them and
if they should be enforced and one of
the first standards that they came up
with was thinking about coding
readability and kind of a simple guide
of writing their code with an audience
in mind one of the things that came up
often is that the code that one might
write for an analysis is very different
than a code and a software engineer
might write for something in production
and thinking about actually telling the
story laying out the assumptions
thinking about all of the things that go
into the analysis as part of how they
write the code and next is thinking
about these best practices you know how
do you actually integrate those into
culture so it's not like you're just
telling someone to do something but it's
actually part of something that people
want to do and you know the last we're
gonna get some new stickers because that
is really motivating and so rather than
the stickers we had before that
everybody got and I think this this idea
might have come from the Airbnb data
science team or another data science
team I'm sure of actually only giving
them out to people who are contributing
certain things and the the core group so
to have that kind of motivation and you
know thinking about there's a lot of
challenges around package and
environment management that are gonna be
coming up in the future that we want to
tackle and so just want to thank
everybody on both the team the current
past and future members and in
particular this working group that my
colleague caught - you just spun up and
thinking about some of these next-level
grown-up challenges and also our other
collaborators in the art community and
then just a shameless plug that we are
still growing
we might double in size again so please
get in touch with me if you're
interested in joining thank you
you
you